what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 28th
of april we did it we're almost [__]
done
[__] april showers bring may flowers
[__] but anyway
the joint is brought to you by
draftkings listen
the ufc was last week i know you guys
had a lot of action last weekend
we got just as much action this week we
got nba
we got pro baseball and i don't know if
you know giraffe kings has one of the
best [__] online casinos out there
that's why i'm with draftkings because
they're the best do yourself a favor
go down to draftkings download the
draftking sports book app right now
and take a look at all the great things
they're doing over at draftkings this is
your [__] weekend
right now the nba is heating up the
playoffs are coming
you know you got major league baseball
and like i said you got the pro fight
league
they've got it all covered they got
boost they got paul a's
they got [__] trifectas they got it
all but it all starts by you downloading
the best sports book app in the [__]
world
draftking sportsbook app right now today
i have no special for you all i'm
telling you is
draftkings is fun it's reliable it's
safe
and you get paid so do yourself a favor
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now
and press in code joey and start your
[__] week off nice
have a great weekend and have some fun
this is not
gambling this is fun 20 here 40 there
50 here and here's what i gotta tell you
what the attorneys make me say okay
[__] uh colorado tennessee
pennsylvania whatever the [__]
if you got a problem [__] 1-800 don't
do it
but if you don't have a problem download
the draftking sportsbook app right now
and let's get this party started it's
time to make a little bakala not much
listen i'm not telling you to become a
[__] degenerate gambler
but i'm telling you you're bored you got
your little [__] uh
unemployment stipend there and what
better way to make a little money
than draftking sports per cap go to
draftkings right now
download the app and press code joey
don't and tell them i sent you they'll
take care of you
the joint is also brought to you by on
it
listen to me there's a little secret
stunting [__] monday they're having
this semi-annual [__] sale you
understand me
they're having a blowout [__] sale if
you've been thinking of alpha brain
shroom tech
new mood the protein puffs
i mean you know and it doesn't stop i
mean they they have everything
that i love i just started drinking
these new little [__]
verotech vitamin c just tremendous
antioxidant support
i mean it never ends so do yourself a
favor go to honor.com right now
read take a look at what they have to
offer i can't do anything for you with
club bats
or kettlebells but uh vitamins
supplements
food i'll get your [__] 10 off do
yourself a favor
go to honor.com right now look read
learn they got great [__] supplements
alpha brain has brought me back i
started my [__] uh
cycle again and i you know i'm having
[__]
dreams and color but it's worth it
because at least i'm
tip top magoo and that's what on it has
for you
is they're selling tip top magoo if you
don't like the alpha brain you can keep
it
and they'll let you keep and they'll
send you your money back that's a
company that believes in the product
that's why you start with alpha brain
and take it from there if you like it
you're gonna love new mood
you're gonna love the shroom tech sport
you're gonna love the shroom tech
immune and they also have alpha brain
and a powder
to mix with your water so you can drink
it while you're working out while you're
going for a walk while you're doing
jumping jacks whatever the [__] you want
go to honor.com right now press in joey
church and get 10 off delivered
right to your [__] house tip
top magoo
let's get this [__] party started
it's the joint [__]
it's wednesday the 28th of april
prayers
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 28th of april where
the [__] did the month go
all i got to tell you is wash your dick
before you [__] piss
because you don't want to give covert to
somebody in their mouth in case you get
a little [__]
i just read i swear to god i don't know
if it was a joke
i don't know if it was a [__] up
article about some dude in montana or
something that got a rash on his penis
and they thought it was coveted i've
been telling you [__] watch
your goddamn hands
i don't know i don't [__] know only
in montana
but uh landscape he needs something but
uh
yeah this is the way it is now just
watch your [__] hands please
we eliminate the flu if you haven't
noticed we eliminated the [__] flu by
washing your [__] hands so
the thing i read the most that [__] me
up was that 80
of people are not showing up for the
second shot jesus christ
jesus [__] christ what are you
[__] scared of america get your [__]
together even
joey went down there the biggest [__]
scared the needles went down there would
i have gone there for a second shot
not really so i don't know what the [__]
i'm complaining about because [__]
80 percent of people are not showing up
that's
a [__] gigantic number do you
understand me so
i don't know what the [__] you guys are
thinking i don't give a [__]
it's your world whatever you want to do
it's up to you listen
it's over it's time to [__] go out
we've been in the house for a [__]
year
so watching [__] bad tv bad podcasts
including this one
bad everything so it's time to get out
and get loose [__] i think
i think biden yesterday said no more
[__] masks i gotta double check that
but
you know what i'm gonna wear my mask for
as long as i have to
i want to double check i don't want no
[__] malukias i don't want no
misunderstandings i don't want
nothing we've made it through this far
[__] it
all right i don't need to go anywhere
i'm sticking to my plans
you know i'm uh
[__] just enjoying the summer with my
family
you know it's so funny they're opening
up the store and people are already
running back
to california so this is going to be a
very
interesting thing to see guys i don't
know what's going on i don't really care
you know when i moved i left that world
behind me
and i'm very happy i did i mean i have a
couple i talk to my friends i check in
with them
i know what's going on but i'm really
not uh
really not aware of everything that's
going on today it's it's kind of weird
i've been caught up in this world
in jersey i'm caught up with my family
you know i'm caught up with my health
i'm trying to you know get a little
stronger make the podcast better every
day get
you know i've been writing a few jokes
and that's not bad
nothing that's gonna [__] blow your
wig off your [__] head i mean there's
nothing genius here
there's no dave chappelle eight minutes
and 29 seconds there's nothing
but i'm writing and that's a start
that's something on the positive [__]
note
and that's because i'm getting better
with the guitar don't get me wrong i'm
not going to
bring back zeppelin i'm not saying that
what i'm saying is that i could see
myself
feeling more comfortable with it and
it's like i've been telling you for
years guys nothing happens on the
[__] couch
nothing i would love for something to
happen on the couch so
you know what i do i don't even sit on
the couch and i play my little [__]
guitar
i come back here i bring my little
[__] laptop i finally cleaned the
screen thank you guys
that's my war laptop you know what i'm
saying that's got kovid
that's got vd that's got a ton of [__]
on that screen god knows
what the [__] is on there i finally
wiped it down but what happened was it
wasn't really that bad
it was that the light in my other office
just beams off it
and it made it look that bad so i wiped
it you guys that are concerned
you're happy now you know what i'm
saying i give you a lock and all you're
worried about is the [__] screen
that's dirty
that's where your head is at you know
what i'm saying so who gives a [__]
uh today's podcast today's guest is
my whole life changed in the early 90s
i mean when i got on stage i got a lot
of guys on patreon now that are
you know thinking of doing comedy a
couple people have hit me up on facebook
and it's interesting to read their
emails
and i tell them all the same thing
listen guys you're going up on stage for
the first
time nobody's going to expect bill bird
to show up
nobody expects bill bird to show up just
get on stage
i listen don't even worry about the
material i don't go i don't give a [__]
if you get on stage and whistle for 10
minutes just get on stage it's
usually it's gonna be three minutes and
the first time you get on stage
every minute seems like an hour you
can't [__] believe it you're like i
got three minutes when is this
when is this portrait gonna end but you
keep going
you keep showing up you know and it
takes you
it takes you it took me two years to
really
understand what i was doing that's why
when i look at videos from other people
and sometimes at night after i do all my
guitar homework
i'll go to a video like some guy last
night was teaching how to play i stay
away by alice in chains trust me i
looked at the video my head almost blew
up it was confusing as [__]
it doesn't matter i'm looking to see
what's ahead
and eventually i will get there i know i
will get there
because of my comedy background you will
get there
put your head down take the ear beatings
take the abuse
and keep going keep showing up and
eventually
you will move up that ring i will
guarantee you
but 93 was a very crucial year for me i
was beat up in boulder
i was all [__] up on drugs it was the
tail end i mean listen i was [__] up
on drugs
my whole goddamn life but this was one
of those times when i was down and out
and i uh came to new york city i go when
you're down and out
and you are lost you have to go back
home
you have to find your way home like i
kind of did this time
i was a little lost i was a little
disoriented i was doing great comedy
wise
the church was doing great but i wasn't
living the life i was living
so you know when you usually do these
type of things it's to get
strength again you know i'm not saying
i'm going to leave jersey and get the
[__] out of here once this all blows
over not at all
what i'm saying is i came back here in
93 to get strength
and i started dabbling in comedy i want
to
take a chance in new york see what's
going on listen if it could if it
happens if you could [__] make it
happen in new york you can make a
[__] anyway that was my [__]
thinking
so i started doing little spots in the
city you know a lot of people didn't
want me to come back i sucked that bad
but one place that was my home was uh
the new york comedy club it was owned by
a gentleman named al martin
and he saw something in me and he would
let me
come to the city whenever the [__] i
wanted to i mean
at that time it was like stand up new
york would let me do spots
the comic strip would just abuse me and
new york comedy club gave me love and
uh that was the start of many great
things for me but that was where i
started to
create comedy relationships and one of
the guys that befriended me
at that time was michael buschetti
he was a sweetheart to me um
he taught me the ropes at the club you
know i'm saying he's the one that got me
in there
and i would try to go down there anytime
mike was there i think i had his number
and we would
communicate and stay in touch and it got
to the point well i'll talk about even
in the zoom my friends would make fun of
me they were like you suck
you should [__] be more like mike
bichetti he's got jokes you got no
[__] jokes
you know it was it was mind-boggling
with my friends but listen my jersey
friends
are like me you know we're very [__]
cut and dry
we're not gonna blow smoke up your ass
they told me you suck
so i was in fact a little jealous of
machete and i was like how can i be
jealous of this guy
well you know i'll be there someday
that's when all that [__] ended i was
like you can't there's no competition in
this game
when you start competing with your
friends is where you're gonna [__]
lose
will they give everything to mike i
don't get nothing work
[__] work you want something work for
it they're not gonna give it to you
obviously he's doing the right thing and
you're not joey so by me being friends
with mike
and me doing spots at the old triple-n i
actually put
the pieces together to become a comedian
i went back to colorado
in october of 93 after about eight
months
of doing spots at the new york comedy
club and getting stronger i
still sucked but i had a direction
and i never ever ever forgot michael
buchetti i always
was like what the [__] ever happened to
him you know we went our own ways
another guy that was lurking at that
club
in 93 was jimmy florentine he was over
there and i did not know him so that
just goes to show you
the people i was around i was
embarrassed that you know
when you do comedy make yourself a
little comedy buddy
and you're going to realize i had a
comedy buddy in new york then i went
back to denver and i had jimmy abeda and
i had
some other guys jeff sargent and my
comedy buddies there and rick kearns and
todd jordan
then when i went to seattle i met josh
wolf and he was my comedy buddy whatever
he got i got
that's what you need you need your
support group even with comedy
the point i'm getting to is today i
bring you michael buchetti on zoom i
know a lot of you [__] don't
want to zoom but hey
it's an interview it's something
different and you get away from me for
an hour i'll be back
don't worry about it i'll be back but uh
right now i want to introduce michael
buschetti enjoy our little short
interview
mike machetti in the [__] house
it's been a zillion and a half years joe
how are you
hey welcome back welcome back to new
jersey first of all
and civilization where everybody will
tell you f off
[__] it's been great man it's great to
be back you are my oldest
if i think about it you are my oldest
comedy friend you befriended me in 1991
at the new york comedy club oh yeah and
anything you should always been a good
guy to me because the thing is
joe this whole business changed from
when we started because
years ago you had to work your butt off
do tons of spots right
you know what i mean get in and now some
imbecile and tick tock has 80 million
hits
and ca is all over what are you gonna do
it's the way life is you just listen we
pick up poison
you know what i'm saying you you you
could go on tick-tock
you go on cameo whatever works for you
you know i mean
if an agent wants can you imagine that
you know how hard it is to get a [__]
agent
somebody does a video they get a million
hits and an agent signs him and then
it's like the guy from [__] uh
that movie my private idaho whatever
that [__] movie the guy with the
shirt pablo
whatever the [__] oh yeah yeah where
where the [__] did he go he disappeared
he got one good movie will farrell
picked him up for the other movie
and then he did the thing with comedy
central and it was so you know
i'm sick and tired of hollywood
and all that [__] not going with the
people who put in the work you watch
these sitcoms
oh yeah it's it's failed sitcoms that go
over and over and over once the
sitcom goes down why would you use this
person the same person that the sitcom
went down with he's a kiss of [__]
death
we got a new show on abc and it's the
same five [__] faces only
reshuffled no they don't catch you they
don't get it so when i watch tv at night
i go
that's [__] you know mike machete
spot
that's jimmy florentine should be
playing that you know
this guy i hate when they say well he's
a comedic
he's a comedian no he's not he's a
comedic actor there's a guy there with a
camera and another guy that says cut
what we do is [__] raw oh god yeah
that's uncensored no it's true because
and the thing is y'all want to let you
know i'm still a mr potato head guy in
this house
you look good though thank you because
it was the last time i saw you brother
oh it's been a long
probably the early 90s you think no
i saw you after that didn't you do a
podcast with artie or something
yeah i did his podcast but i think he
was supposed to be on there and then
he had some anxiety issues and then you
know
i think that's what happened right that
was what it was it was just
right yes yes you were doing the podcast
with him
yeah it was fun i miss him i haven't
spoken to him because
the sad thing is i don't have his
current cell number email because
he changes constantly all the time and i
can't get him
you got to get away from the drug
dealers i know
you got to get him out i wish him i wish
him all the love in the world
i i love that guy with all my [__]
heart
i know that you new york comics love
them with all he's he's
a breath of [__] fresh air you know
oh yeah
and i'm sure that everybody just wants
him to get well
we all do because joe i've been sober 24
years now saint patrick's day haven't
touched a drink
was that your poison alcohol oh it was
horrible joe i would be
if we were still if i was still drinking
now
you'll be grabbing me by my ankles i'll
be out of the boston place and throw me
in the back of the car
because i would be becoming such an
idiot when i drank did you go to
meetings did you go to rehab
uh no i just stopped my own i was very
blessed because
my dad went to aaa for years he was a
big believer in that you know what joe
i whatever it takes to get you
well again you know what i mean if you
need meetings perfect you know to work
for you
i just did it on my own but my dad was a
big believer in aaa and the thing is it
works for you
to get you well that's the most
important thing do you miss it
uh once in a while like i'll go to deli
and i'll be like
see a foster blogger or budweiser or
anything i'm like i need one of those
cold bad boys
now how would you feel if he just had
one beer with a sausage and pepper
sandwich
would you feel you relapse do you think
he would it would become a problem i
mean oh would be a problem joe because
that one
would lead to me drinking 12 more
sleeping outside at 7-eleven
you know my demon was cocaine whoa and i
know for a fact
that i could never once i quit it and i
was off it for three weeks and whatever
and then it turned into three months
then turned into three years
i always believed that if i ever touched
it again i would just die
like in my world i think if i cut a line
of cocaine up and snort it i would
[__] die on the spot
that's what my belief is now you're
right because
and it's so scary joe that people can
let themselves get that addicted to
stuff it's it's
really hard i mean joe i i just turned
60 and i lost
family friends that were way under 30 to
addiction
out you know drug and alcohol and it's
i'm
i'm i don't even know how i made it this
far and some of the other people i know
died half my age you know i just had
surgery
and they gave me oxycodones oh no
you know and it was i read all about it
i checked in with two junkies that i
knew you know and i
talked to them about it about uh
pill use you know i had a friend that
had a problem with pills i talked to him
about it
and he told me that the big thing that
there's a difference between oxycodone
and oxycontin oxycontin is the one that
comes in the shell and people break it
and snort it i guess i i don't [__]
know
i had the little five milligrams and
you know they it was it was never fun
they were okay for two or three days
and then i felt how they took over my
body they made me
very emotional and oh no yeah it was a
[__] nightmare and i'll tell you
that you don't need that nightmare again
no oh no thank god i did them for
uh i stopped on theoxies
and i started breaking them in half i
would do everything i could just to
avoid
just to stay ahead of the pain and then
i downloaded i told them i had 13 oxys
left that said it's over
cut me down they cut me down the viking
i didn't do them for like the first two
days and then i did a couple of them and
they're still in the [__] draw that's
it it's over i just i don't want to get
re-hooked on anything at 50 [__]
eight
no no no because i mean not only that
joe the thing is
it's horrible to be hooked to anything i
mean
the only advice you have now is food i
gotta wash my i mean i like to eat but i
mean
you know that's bad too if you're not
careful well i'll tell you what
when i moved to new jersey i knew one
thing
i know that i could blow up to 400
pounds within 90 days
wow and once i got here i did put on
like 20 pounds
right off the bat i put on 20 pounds
because everywhere you go
somebody's handing you a slice of pizza
always [__] pizza everywhere in
jersey you go to any party
you go to a kid's party they got pizza
and i live in south jersey and this is
i'm surrounded
by oh god brooklyn these [__]
italians
aren't [__] around they argue about
pizza they bring it from staten island
decoration they're like handed out
calzones
over there i knew it and between the
chinese food
the [__] cuban food the italian food
i knew i would blow up to 400 pounds so
i went on
weight watchers even double than what i
was doing in l.a like
i don't even use butter anymore like
that's how scared i am
well under i've lost i lost maybe 20
pounds during the surgery
just god bless you how you feeling now i
feel good the knee bothers me
from time to time but you know what you
take a couple tylenols
you put some ice on the knee and it's
way better than anything else you could
[__] do
ice ice is [__] tremendous how much
comedy were you doing
at the time of the pandemic uh you know
what joe it's kind of weird because
back one weird thing about me is i
backed off a little bit i started
working more acting stuff
i've taken a class for like 14 months
now richard klein
it was awesome larry from three's
company okay
i've been taking a lot of improv uh
comedy classes
you know dramatic improv but i'm just
doing stuff in fact you know it's crazy
today's been such a blessing being on
your show i also today
have my cd on siriusxm all day today
good what a blessing it is it's like you
on here now and then with them so
when it rains in foster show am i right
or wrong right you know mike man
we've done it all you have nothing to
prove you know it's weird when you've
done something for 10 years and then you
do something for 20 years
and now we're both like seasoned [__]
veterans this is 30 years
and you have all these decisions to make
you know and
for you it was getting into a dramatic
improv class to make yourself better
this comedy game what most people at
home don't understand is that
we're always growing we're always doing
things to grow
we try to podcast we grew with it you
know for some comics during the pandemic
they went on tick tock
that works for them you know absolutely
i don't know anything about it
god bless all the comics that made it
through
oh yeah they had a switch there game up
they had to do [__] you know zoom
shows i had a
you know i had a move i had to pick up
and re-route and then restart everything
and look we're here today we're here
today
well you have to take a couple steps
back to make some forward
yes yes absolutely and i
took a little chunk out of my life and
uh
you know the stand up hurts a little bit
that it's at
half capacity and all that [__] i got my
shots
oh how do you feel i feel like a million
bucks i got it on monday
oh good i gotta get my second one in a
few weeks but
how'd you feel at the first one i felt
like i was i got a job
oh nice good and i got to tell you it
was uh
it was painless i want to complain
i would wish i would complain to you
guys don't go down there they're gonna
[__] hurt you
they were the nicest people in the world
i didn't feel it
uh i felt a little weird that night you
know i took the tylenols how they
recommended
i stayed it that's the most important
thing to keep drinking fluids
oh yeah and then you'll be you know 90
at least if
you get it now you're not going to end
up in that bad
shape they say we'll see yeah we'll see
i mean i was afraid to get into the
first because i was like you know what
about the side effects but you know what
joe we got to end it somehow and
back to normal you know what i mean you
got to take a chance
well man you know this pandemic
has taught us a lot oh yeah you haven't
learned anything during this pandemic
especially about yourself
what you can't can do can't do
can't do can do and what you could
what we've realized we could we can do
like
we realized a lot of things that we had
to move forward
stand-up ended what the [__] do you want
me to do no clubs are open what are you
gonna do you're gonna stand on the
corner and do stand up until somebody
throws a bottle at you
so you had to reroute your energies
during this for me i got together with a
partner finally and started writing a
book
oh nice congratulations together with
mike i got a new
producer and we started this from
scratch and
[__] people hated me and you know but
i didn't give a [__]
you know i wanted to start over i felt
bored i felt uh
i was in my comfort zone which is never
too good
no great to be in a company right
absolutely
you know it was too easy i'm i created a
paradise in l.a for myself
i created the paradise that i wanted to
and then it became easy like it was too
boring i drove two blocks to do a
podcast
i drove eight blocks to do a a set
i drove two blocks to the gym two blocks
to cryotherapy
two blocks to the weed store
i had this little [__] thing in
studio city
yeah in your own village i had my own
little [__] village and then
this pandemic hit me and my wife had
always spoken about moving back here
we have been speaking about it since
2016.
we were gonna move back here anyway this
just sped up the [__] process
and i tell you what i'm happy i [__]
did it i feel better
i am better i'm a way better person you
know i that's the important thing
that's the most important thing you just
said because joe i never lived in l.a
i was out there on and off yet right i
liked it
for some reason they they got my comedy
out there for some reason what in new
york
they did for some reason that i don't
know joe
i mean i was going to ask you right it
seems like they're like different stuff
in l.a
more than new york dutch well it depends
where you go
you know when you're in in hollywood
let's say you're at the improv
the laugh factory or the comedy store
you know you have to assume there's
industry in the room some type of
industry whatever
and that messes with comics heads you
know when you first get to la
you're thinking somebody's watching you
that could change your life
you know then you realize that nobody
could change your life but you
or you're right be [__] funny that's
that's what happens to people in l.a
when you first go to l.a
you go on stage thinking [__] johnny
disney's here
oh [__] put me in the next [__]
coco
no no and even if he's there whatever
you have to perform to make them laugh
that's the confusion a lot of people go
to la to become stars
i went to la just to be a comic
and i didn't even want to do that like i
i didn't think i would survive in l.a
mike bushetti i mean the last time i saw
you
we were doing spots at the new york
comedy club i had taken a stand-up
writing class there okay course
the guy was great i bumped into him 20
years later in la
he was a writer on a tv show i think it
was al martin who owned the club right
and we were working oh aldo
yeah he definitely did at that time
absolutely this is still on it today
no another guy does today now amelia
owns it
like probably seven six seven years but
now that's where i met you because but
the thing is
joe you got me right away comedy-wise
right
and the thing is you know being unique
and different like i was
some comics chastise me in new york
they're like oh he's not mainstream like
seinfeld or whoever
you know what i mean this and even
industry people have seen something
different come along they're like
oh what is this well you know
i mean listen mike you
want to be different i would love to be
john mulaney
i would love for my comedy to be bill
burrs
you know we all aspire to do something
but at the end
you have to be yourself that's the key
to comedy joe in life
that's the key to comedy and when people
tell you that in the beginning there's a
lot of young comics that listen to this
show
it's such a cliche [__] line when
people say it to you just be yourself
just be yourself and you're like i'm an
[__] you know i'm a [__] [__]
what are you talking about be myself
what are you talking about
and then you understand it that what
they're looking for is
what you bring to the game that little
different aspect
stand up is very untraditional it's not
bill burr
me he neither i'm not i'm not my
knowledge you know what i mean i'm not
that kind of comic i know
no and uh you were very funny
thank you joe so you because you but
you're yourself like i am because
i was i watched your podcast the thing i
like about you is
there's no nonsense with you like
everybody like cow is
into people joe like oh my god they're
like if the cursed agents are gonna like
me
you know what i think right yeah you you
don't
you like you went on anyway you didn't
tab
shut the [__] up [__] i'm doing a
podcast
i know i told them that earlier
how many kids you got are they kids oh
no they're my family's here
okay good how many people over there we
got like four or five and
gel we got a five pound chihuahua
upstairs my brother's dog
five pounds what are you the mexican
number the thing is she thinks she's a
90 pound rottweiler
but what was really interesting about
our relationship that i never told
anybody at all
that's why when you reached out i'm like
you know what this is perfect to tell
podcast people
because they learn i want the young
comics to learn
that this is where i learned it in 1991
obviously as you remember when you
performed at the new york comedy club or
any other club in new york you had to
bring a few people
you know you had to bring a few people
so
you know god blessed me with great
friends growing up in jersey you know
that
supported me they were in shock that i
was doing comedy
i really met you in 93.
not 91 91 is when i started
93 is when i met you march 93
i lived in new york i came back here i
was having such a problem in boulder
and i said let me go back to new york
and give this problem some space
joe i thought you were the mob when i
first met you looked like a tough guy
i thought you were mafia when i first
seen you i was raw back then when i
first met you in 93 i was still doing
some crazy
[__] but i had to bring people all the
time to the shows and you would always
be there
and my friends till this day
still love you there's one guy wow
that's that's
awesome because you used to have a line
that said
you work in a bakery you're in all your
hearts oh can i say it for you i haven't
said it yet
but thank you what was the joke i worked
in handicap bakery
they put me in charge of the tots oh my
god
look at that 30 [__] you 28 years
later i still [__] remember this
because
on the way home my friends would be
torturing me they're like you got to be
more like mike buchetti
thank you they're like you suck you got
to be more like mike and i'm like
[__] suckers so for the first couple
days i'm like god damn it i was kind of
jealous of you and then i'm like
bro i gotta do what he's doing he's
different
he's not doing what anybody else is
doing that's what my friends were
telling me
so at first i was jealous of you i'm
like [__] my buddy
my friends would say to me you got to be
more like mike and i'm like [__] you
[__] mike what do you mean i got to be
like michael jordan mike
what mike are you talking about that's
funny because but the thing is
at the end of the day when i first
started i went to pips in brooklyn
besides new york comedy club right and
god rest his soul
i was up there and what was his name a
set
seth said schultz right
uh i went there i was very dirty at the
time joe i was wearing a black little
jacket this is what he told me speaking
about being yourself he goes
he said i can see you totally love your
embrace clay which i still built to this
day
but you know what he told me you can't
be him and he can't be you you got to be
yourself
and that stayed with you yeah that
stayed with you for a long [__] time
mike
joe i actually met him years ago and
when i first met
i had one very funny story about him i
met andrew lash clay in 2005
for the first time at caroline's right
uh
jim florentine introduced me to him with
don james they would open it from at the
time right
and um i went over to him joe i was like
nine-year-old kid a little new kid from
the block concert like a little
like so excited to meet him and uh
he broke my balls the first time and i'm
like whoa
you know but then i met him a couple of
times but
joe he became a good guy to me when i
was an audie show he hugged me
right and he told me i became a fan of
yours now
after watching you and that like blew my
mind to hear that because
joe for 30 years i watched him and for
him to tell me that
it was like one of them an emmy mike
buschetti
i came out of prison and for new year's
eve
they put me in a halfway house when you
get out of prison and for new year's eve
i rented out the room in the halfway
house i think they charged me 50 bucks
and i played his special for people the
one from philadelphia the one that blew
him up
you know oh yeah so
you and i were both products of andrew
dice clay i mean that was a product of
richard pryor i loved richard
oh richard there's nobody like him
andrew was who pushed me on to the stage
because when i saw andrew i said to
myself jesus christ this [__] is
saying what i think
oh yeah what i think on a daily basis
this [__] guy is repeating so i have
to i have a chance at this
because i'm not the only one that thinks
this way
well he comes up to you would you like
to buy a flower for the lady
why don't you take that flower and let
me plant it in your ass all that [__]
that's the way i used to think but i
couldn't let people know that
i lived in colorado and people were nice
and stuff and i'd be like what the [__]
in my mind
i'd be i'd be thinking like andrew dice
clay
oh it's a lot different than joe like
other parts of the country that are laid
back and chilled out and like
you can't beat joe pesci in idaho
yeah no no but andrew for me
was like the first year that i saw him
at the store
i did not have the balls to go up to him
for all you people at home
i think that you go up to people i
didn't approach andrew dice clay even
though i was a regular at the store
and doing spots in front of him you know
following him you know i would go up at
one and he'd go up at [__] 10.
i didn't have the balls to go up to him
one night he came up to me to settle an
argument
and i chimed in and that's how we became
friends
well because joe i don't like
approaching famous people at all
i get very like laid back you know what
i mean because
unless i know them because get
introduced to them because
i don't know how they are as people
first of all you know what i mean right
and second of all like if you're working
on stuff you've done i mean
it's not time to take out of you know
hawaiian shirt and take a million
pictures of these people
we're doing stuff with them and regular
people don't get that sometimes
how long did you stay at the new york
comedy club after i left how many years
were you there
oh god i would say i left there back in
like 1999 but i still haven't been i
haven't been there probably like
three or four years but it changed a lot
i mean physically
i mean it's [__] i sit here i'm
looking at you and i i still see that
same kid from [__] 28 years ago
you know it's just uh it's so great to
see you it's been forever because
it's great to see you too man and we joe
we have a couple of friends and
commenter i love
that that you know for years someone
wanted me to tell you hi actually
what he called christy miller how is she
doing
she's really cool because she talked
about it she goes she goes i love diaz
because
from the comedy store and you know she
was very cool to me to try to help me
reach out to you
phylicia michaels i know for a million
years
great lady great lady i'm gonna give her
a call today as a matter of fact i
haven't spoken to in a few weeks
and i was wondering where the [__] she's
been but yeah they're both
solid [__] doug joe i never
i went to the comedy store i the only
place i ever went to in la
spots when i was out there was the
improv in l.a i never been on the
factory or the store
i went to the comedy store like five
years ago right just
hang there you know who i went into and
they were so nice to me there
uh martin lawrence i ran into him
outside and he he talked to me for like
20 minutes because all i said to him joe
was i loved you on the tv show martin
that's all i had to say to him right
we just talked about everything but
comedy for like 20 minutes
one of the coolest people ever in my
life you know
it's really weird when you have a great
experience with people
you know i mean you went up to martin
lawrence you didn't know what he was
going through
you didn't know if his wife served him
with divorce papers that day
you didn't know if his kid spilt milk on
his [__] stereo people don't know the
moment before you see that celebrity
what they're thinking
and you know you you approach people you
know you try
like i remember seeing richard gere and
i [__] hated him at the time
but i didn't have the balls to go up to
him i wouldn't i would never think of
going up to him but it is pretty nice
like the other day i went to get a
cheesesteak
and as i was walking in some guy looked
at me and he goes is that you
and i go it depends who you think it is
he was an african-american
he was an african-american kid really
sweet kid
you know didn't ask for a picture at
that time i didn't have the covert shot
you know so i wouldn't take a picture
anyway
but we had such a pleasant little
conversation 12-minute conversation
about comedy
we shook hands and we left he felt good
about the conversation
and i felt really good about the
conversation
it's the conversations where they
where people try to get too much from
you i think
that bar because i've been on a set
of movies where i've been talking to a
major
star about you know what's going on
at the moment there it's not like i'm
telling them about my personal life or
that i smoke pot or whatever
i'm asking them about a scene in a movie
or something
and i've seen how they are you know i've
seen how they've reacted to me they're
short
they're long they're into it you know
and i
never judged them you know that's why it
kills me when people go
i worked on a movie and i worked with
justin bieber oh my god he's so cool you
dumb [__]
you saw him for two days for three hours
you know that's how you yeah you really
don't know like you said because joe
you said earlier it makes so much sense
because when i
when you meet somebody you do not know
went on in their life that day
no you have no [__] idea you know i
spent 17 weeks with adam sandler
well i'll go i'll go up in front of a
[__] bible put my hand on it and i'll
you know testify in open court that he
was one of the best bosses i ever had in
my life
and he was a great guy but i was around
him for 17 [__] weeks
six days a [__] week i got to see him
on his bad days i got to see him on his
good days
and he was a gentleman at every [__]
single opportunity
i kind of joe i never met him but i mean
you span him as well in his movies
and i don't know sometimes you can't lie
who you are on camera you know what i
mean for some reason it's like
i mean i picture all the characters he
plays
you know that's part of him and i
picture he must be a cool guy like that
you know what i mean because certain
people you can't hide it sometimes
no you know when i think of him in real
life
i think the mo the picture that reflects
who he is the most is 50 first dates
i really liked him the 50 first dates i
i didn't watch any of his earliest stuff
i watched i'll be honest right now you
know
i watched happy madison and i didn't
like it i didn't like that style of
humor so i didn't
i didn't become an adam sandler fan
until i worked for adam sandler
and then i watched every movie and i
watched it from a different perspective
i had heard there were some problems on
the set of happy madison where even the
director
didn't like what was going on and he
went in and complained about him
and they fired him and so i was never
i didn't i didn't hate adam sandler i
just didn't like his movies at the time
that's what i'm trying to say
oh yeah once i read for him met him
it was [__] like a breath of fresh
air because
he really i don't know how to say this
he ruined the curve that's what i'm
trying to say
because i thought that everybody was
going to turn out to be like
adam and boy was i wrong oh no he's
untouchable
no i've worked with some [__]
douchebags that people think are great
people
you know people if you talk to them oh
that person is so great
i've been on a set with him for two
weeks that person's a [__] scumbag i
won't say that because
it's not for me to say of course but
i've worked with some [__]
great i was watching
what's that show uh i'm dying up here
you know it's on showtime it's about the
comedy store
the lady who's the star of that
movie who plays mitzi shaw per se
i never met her i was dying to meet her
forever i never
got the pleasure meeting pot not not
mitchy sure but the lady who plays
mitchy sure and i'm dying up here
i did two episodes of that show
and i had to spend a day with her like
four hours in the room it was just me
and her having a conversation
but something had happened so her and i
got stuck in this room talking and i'll
tell you what it was a [__] when i
left there
my dick was hard because she was
everything i thought she could be like
she was sweet
she was [__] smart you know when i
looked at her the first two takes i did
with her
and i'm not ashamed to say this i [__]
up just from looking at her you
you got it
yeah you get intimidated you're like
this [__] person
she played opposite denzel washington
and the equalizer she
i know on this it flush your mind
because it blows your mind and here you
are doing lines with her and you're just
a dirty comic from the [__] comedy
store from jersey
i'm just a dirty [__] comic from
jersey so i'm sitting there going
and she was so sweet to me like i've
i've
i've i love to write a book of the
actors who saved
my [__] life on the set i did svu
that lady marisa
whatever hagerty right i think was
[__]
tremendous she was tremendous it was the
coldest day ever in new york city and it
was me and her
and she's like why are you standing out
here coming here with me and i'm like
this is tremendous i'm in a hallway with
this [__] girl from svu and she's
talking to me and she's being nice and
sweet
some people are just great people all
around some people
and you know what when to be a good
actor
to be a good comic to be a good
like to be good at those things you have
to have
a great side of humanity to you you got
to be a good human is right
you gotta like to get the good results
from comedy
you gotta pull the younger people in up
of course you got to help them not
listen i bumped into 200 scam artists in
the last 10 years that
thought that coming on the podcast it
was going to change their life i'm not
i'm just taught those talking to your
producer about that earlier
joe how much have you been annoyed by
people that's why i was very cautious
when i reached out to you because
i know you had an army of animals
harassing you like joe what's up baby
hey pal
you know i mean all kinds of nonsense
some idiots well you know the hollywood
scene you know everybody's your buddy
everybody's your power why you guys
it's like life when you got a bag of
blow it's tough to have enemies you know
what i'm saying if you show up with a
big bag of blood everybody loves you
they forgot about all your [__] past
disgrace and everything you know
um i i i helped
the people who i saw were helping
themselves
if i saw a girl like carmen morales
busting her ass at the store
i reached out to her if i saw you know
jessica wellington
at the store fighting for her life i
reached out to those young comics
because i was one of those comics at one
time
and all i needed was something to give
me a glimmer of hope for 90 days
oh yeah when you're a comic when you're
in the arts
when you're a human being you need a
glimmer of hope
every 90 days to give you hope for the
next 90 days
easily because joe one the best thing i
like about sandler is
he brought henry winkler back to life
now well not back to life because you
know why
people still know the fonts and henry
for years maybe not on screen but
he was producing directing stuff but he
helped give him a whole new generation
of people
to home again and that's what it's all
that's what this is all about at the end
of the day
you know when people get mad at joe
rogan for getting a hundred million
[__] dollar deal and now they
they're pissed off at him and this and
what already
they don't understand that he lifted up
200 [__] comics
they're morons you know why because they
just first of all
they just want to come look this has
been my philosophy life
okay when something bad happens to you
or whatever
you know if you can control it and
change it
do it right but if it's out of your
control just live with it and try to
move on and that's it because
don't be a crybaby you don't sit in your
ass you complain and brag about other
people
just keep going i knew the people that
i saw people at the county store i saw
people at the improv i saw people at the
haha
i saw comics that they had that look in
their eye
and i would say to them hey you want to
come on the podcast and
i would see them you know do things
afterward
and they would make my dick hard well i
hate when people think that
well by going on a podcast you're going
to [__] it's going to change your life
that's the people i didn't want on my
podcast
no they think they're going to be in 20
movies after that
people those are the same people that
think that if you go on rogan
you're going to get a hollywood deal no
those are not you're not going to get a
hollywood deal
when i went on rogan i knew it would
give me a light
but now that light i had to fill it i
had to film
i proved myself after that and people
came on for the ride and some people
didn't you know of course
people think you know it's going to be
one thing that's going to put you over
the top
it's a i mean i'll give you it's not
what we're going to say you'll give me
an example oh joe i'm going to tell you
one quick funny thing
i was in the movie the family with
robert de niro
okay i was up for one of the roles of
an fbi agent guarding him i was in
callbacks but i didn't get it but the
director
luke the son liked me a lot he casted me
as a acidic jewish guy
being held at gunpoint by dinero
listen to this joe i i got to the set
that day
i'm sorry i got to the set that day
right my heart stopped when i see the
narrow on the set
right so i didn't talk to him at all i
met my business
right then he started laughing with me
right on the set joe
i mean working with people like him you
work with sandler they have such an
energy
i mean when you're doing a scene with
them they pull you in like a vacuum
it's crazy it's so hard to explain like
joe you get on the show with adam he
pulls you in like a vacuum acting wise
am i right or wrong like
like santa like dinero pulled me in like
when i was in the scene with him
i seen jimmy conway come out of him i've
seen
all kinds of characters come out of them
on that on that scene it was
mind-blowing
i've said the same story about him that
when i did the scene with him
the first time he came up to me that it
was like cut the first two scenes
because you see jimmy conway
you see taxi driver you see all these
[__] that
you know you see all those characters
that he played but
i'ma tell you something when i did
grudge match with him
i went to the set the day before i was
supposed to shoot just to look around
you know me we're hustlers you gotta go
down there and see what oh yeah what's
going on
so i went down and it was so funny i
watched him and hello cool j do their
first scenes together well
they were talking they were you know
having a great time
next thing you know cameras around them
sure enough first two or three scenes
hello cool j couldn't focus and
then i was like that's weird they were
just having a great time
when i the next day when i did my scene
with him and it happened to me that's
when i realized
why it happened to hello cool j because
once you're focused with those guys and
it's just you and him you're like oh my
god this is the guy from [__]
goodfellas
this is the guy from godfather 2. this
is the guy from this
mean streets and it just [__] with your
head it's like i believe that that's
what happens to people
before they fight conor mcgregor oh yeah
they psyched themselves out and they
forget what the [__] is going on conor
mcgregor is just a human being he's a
great fighter
but he's just a human being you know
that's what i think happened to dustin
poirier dustin poirier fought him the
first time got caught up by the lights
and the glamour went down
the second time he knew what happened to
him exactly what not to fall for and he
see them he attacked him no
i'm not putting anybody down here i'm
just stating what i think happens to you
of course because it's concentration and
focus because
joe that's like a boxing in the ring
with with ali
and i'm thinking i'm going to have a
bologna sandwich for dinner tomorrow
i hear you buddy i hate you mike
bushetti i'm happy that you reached out
i'm so glad you have to thank you for
it's been having me years because
first of all joe i have a funny feeling
after this
comics you're going to be like dude
what's up now people are
i don't give a [__] you know i don't
care that's why i'm on
you know i just want to do i wanted the
world to know that you and i go back to
i want the world to know that i was
jealous of you
at one time i'm not a [__]
you know i tell it like it is i was very
jealous of you until i
saw what you were doing and you opened
up my eyes so
it was so it's so good i would love to
see you in person when we can because
once this thing is over i'm getting my
final shot
the 17th i hope to see you live what
clubs do you usually go to new york city
uh you know whoever put me up
which ones so far i like first of all
uh new york comedy club gotham i
i did stuff at the west side which
opened recently
stand-up new york and caroline's i love
those for the rest of them
you know michelle is so incredible to
see it virtually anyway
i'll take this and give it a month and
i'll see you somewhere in the city and
give you a hug
deal thank you joe i love you buddy
thank you mike bushetti thank you for
joining
all this friendly comedy what is this
coming out uh soon after two days soon
soonish i'll keep you posted thank you
thank you your best friend
beautiful thank you for everything i
love you thank you
what's happening you bad [__] i
hope you enjoyed our little chit chat
a little tate tate with my main man
micah buchetti it was great uh you know
it's been years so
i want to just i wanted to show you guys
that i had roots even back in new york
and the early 90s i just didn't [__]
show up here guys this is all based on
hard work
and uh boredom and abuse and [__] you
know
drug use and drug abuse there was a
bunch of things involved here
but i realized i ended up uh getting to
a plateau but it all started
with the things i learned in 93 and
michael buschetti
befriending me and letting me know that
i was on the right [__] path
listen i want to thank you guys for a
great week of podcast a great month of
podcast we tried our best
we're trying to get the feel i know a
lot of you guys don't like the zoom i
know a lot of you is like
me straight up and that's exactly what
we're gonna do we have another great
zoom for you next week and another great
podcast i'm not gonna tell you what it
is
and we're gonna keep moving [__]
forward because that's what we do
if you want more of joey diaz i'm on
patreon
the nfts are coming soon i'm going to be
doing them through patreon and probably
putting them online
so we got a little couple things going
on uh for you [__] that have
been bugging me
we have an interested publisher
so hopefully this week uh we'll have a
little conference call
with a publisher for the book at least
we're getting there there's not been no
offers made nothing like that
but i just want to let you know that
this is what i've been doing during this
period every day
three days a week me and eric are
talking for you guys uh
listen i always put pictures up of
edibles to [__] with you guys you know
my friends send me edibles they come
back they bring me edibles
i'm not doing anything it's so weird how
i haven't even smoked today that's how
crazy it is i was talking to rogan the
other day and i'm like
rogues i'm smoking a [__] third
of what i was smoking and i had some
[__] i went out to dinner with a friend
of mine
sunday night it was like we had nothing
to do and next thing you know me and my
wife were headed to dinners with
different [__] people was great
and uh i went to a restaurant and took
my mask off and i was sitting in there
and there was a couple people in the
restaurant
so i kind of felt weird right away you
got like a [__] sore throat you come
home and you're like i gotta shut the
road
you know your mind plays tricks on you
so i smoked that night and [__] my
lungs started i'm like [__]
i got covered now because you could
still get covered even if you get the
vaccine it's just not so severe
but the numbers are down to 0.9 or
whatever who gives a [__]
listen there's a light at the tunnel we
made it through
i was here with you guys since last
march doing podcasts
i took one month off and i stuck it out
with you [__] and i let you
know if you listen to those
podcasts from march and april uh the
church of 2020
you'll know i was telling you that this
day was always coming we just had to be
patient
take care of ourselves stay safe and
we're here
that's it we're going to have a great
[__] summer have a great week i want
to thank all my sponsors this week
draftkings
on it cbd lion don't forget to register
for the playstation and zip recruiter
they were great
they're always great i love my [__]
sponsors anyway i love you guys thank
you for enjoying it
and we'll be back monday may 3rd
tip top magoo the beginning of a whole
new [__] month i love you [__]
have a great week and a great weekend
you know where to find me
love you all right [__]
i want to thank mike buschetti i want to
thank honor
but most importantly i want to thank you
guys
i want to thank draftkings i want to
thank you guys for listening
for enjoying for trying something new
you know you know i'm [__] swinging
for the bats here
i'm trying myself guys this is all new
for everybody but
before we go listen to me it's going to
be a quiet weekend
people aren't looking to [__] do
anything this is the perfect time
to hit draftkings because they're not
hyping anything you understand me
nice and easy the nba is right there for
you you're getting ready for the nba
playoffs you got major league baseball
the lines are still a little [__]
light
you could pick yourself a winner you
know if you're having problems look up
to danny b
sports go and look at the philly
godfather for help whatever the [__]
whoever can help you i'm not telling you
that you're gonna go make a million
dollars on draftkings what i'm telling
you it's fun you keep it fun
if you want to go on then they got one
of the best online casinos
in the [__] world listen draftkings
sportsbook app is one of the best
[__] apps out there to gamble on
that you could ever want your life so do
me a favor download it right now today
pressing code joey and get your
[__] party started
you're like joey what are you talking
you're gonna get your party started
light
maybe friday night an nba game maybe
saturday a little major league baseball
game
sunday night they got that major league
baseball on espn you can bet the game
while you're watching
i'm not telling you to bet 500 or 6. i'm
not trying to create a problem
all i'm telling you is to look at it as
a way to have fun
download the draftking sportsbook app
take a look at what the [__] is going on
tonight and press encode
joey to get your party started real
quick
i got this is what the attorneys make me
say
tennessee colorado new jersey only okay
i don't want no [__] problems if you
got a gambling problem 1-800
go with it i don't know what it is in
indiana i [__] forgot
but if you got a gaming problem take
care of your problem but if not
download the draftking sportsbook app
and get your party started with [__]
joy i've been telling you this since
january
and you're still sitting there
scratching your head the joint is also
brought to you by one of my all-time
favorites on it why because if it's not
farming i live on this [__]
i live on the pro you look at me going
joe you lost this weight how did you do
it you want me to tell you
i eliminated night eating so if i get
hungry at night i just eat one of those
seven gram
protein bites whether it's the coconut
almond or the peanut butter chocolate
that [__] tremendous seven
grams of protein three grams of sugar
that's what i live off alpha brain is
tremendous shroom tech is tremendous
shroom tech immune and shroom tech sport
the protein chips are
listen just go down and read i can't do
nothing for you with the kettlebells and
the club bats but a song
as long as you're looking at supplements
and something to heal the mcp
all i'll get you 10 off on your first
order go to honor.com right now
preston joey preston church get 10
percent off
delivered right to your [__]
house and get your haunted experience
started okay
why [__] get off the couch let's do
this walk in a little alpha brain a
little reading
a little journaling and get your life
back i love you [__] i want to
thank all you [__]
for listening and for having my back and
for supporting me and i want to thank
honet
draftkings cbd lion and zip recruiter
for having my back this week have a
great weekend
i love you [__] stay black
[Music]
so
you